hello freak [ __ ] I'd be frozen and
liquid okay and it's some numbers that
tell you whether it's acting like it's
frozen or liquid just like I could
describe the beer I could define some
numbers that would tell me whether the
beer was frozen or liquid and so as the
universe cooled that cosmic fluid which
is everywhere all these elementary
particles if you wish that are
permeating space suddenly found
themselves preferring as the universe
cooled down to be in a certain
configuration rather than another
configuration okay and it really is no
different in the arbitrary state of an
icicle no exactly
it's just essentially as arbitrary it's
not magic and it's not as if you know if
we in some sense the accidents of what
the dust that's on your window and the
wind that's blowing and everything else
is going to determine what that what
that pattern looks like but every day if
you had a new cold day the icicle
pattern would look different okay
it's not as if every day you'd have the
same icicle pattern on your window it
would be different and that's what I
mean by an accident it's not as if the
laws of physics at some level couldn't
have told you that if you knew all the
configurations on that day why would
look one way or another but it's not
significant I guess what I mean there's
no special significance to that pattern
that meant God meant it to be and
there's no special significance to the
universe in which we live that meant God
meant it to be it could have been quite
different we should celebrate that it's
not quite different because you and I
can have this conversation so it's a
wonderful thing that it is the way it is
and let's celebrate the world that we've
evolved and I can still say that we're
in this country we've evolved a
consciousness so that we can appreciate
all of the wonders of the universe let's
celebrate that so it doesn't mean we're
meaningless just because the universe
has no purpose we make our own purpose
in our own life it means to me in some
sense the life is more purposeful there
isn't someone pulling the strings we're
pulling the strings and so it's okay to
live in a purposeless universe it
doesn't make life worse it makes it much
better we just always describe
significance to things that happen to us
the physicists Richard Feinman used to
used to go up to people and used to say
you won't believe what happened to me
today
you won't believe and people say why do
you say absolutely nothing okay because
when things happen to you suddenly
they're significant you know you have a
million crazy dreams and then one night
you dream that your friend is going to
break their arm the next day they break
their leg you go oh my god I'm
clairvoyant you know or he'll say this
you'll say you know I just saw a license
plate
you wouldn't believe I just saw license
it was Jay two four seven nine six can
you believe it because you know that's a
significant seeing a license plate that
says one one one one one one one or
license plate says as I am God okay
they're all just as significant but were
the things that appear to mean something
to us suddenly take on some significance
because we're hardwired to want to
believe just like the x-files said we
want to believe we all want to believe
we were why well here's the reason we
want to ascribe meaning to everything
and I think there's an evolutionary
reason for that for example if you're a
early modern human on the Savannah and
Africa the leaves can be rustling in the
trees next to you you can say yeah no
reason or you can say maybe there's a
lie in there and what happened was so
maybe there's a lion causing maybe
there's a cause for that happening now
that those of our potential ancestors
that said ah isn't a reason they got
eaten okay the the ones that didn't
other ones are reproduced right and so
in some sense we're kind of hardwired by
evolution to want to find purpose and
meaning and everything but isn't that
just recognizing danger or potential
danger of course it is in that case
but-but-but-but of side effect of
anticipating danger is to ascribe
significance to things that may not
you're much luckier if you're much not
luckier but you're much more likely to
survive if you ascribe significance to
everything perhaps in the early days
then if you ascribe significance to
nothing but when you say when you're
talking about significance essentially
you're talking about divine significance
well nobody sort of it can be divine
significance but it can just be you can
think it there's more more to it than
then we meets the eye
right
you're talking about clairvoyance or
when you're talking about some sort of a
divine intervention by a deity yeah
you're talking about something powerful
this is the one that is meant to be the
leader of this tribe
yeah well that's but nothing will lead
us right yeah but it works at all levels
it works at all levels from the fact
that the leaves are rustling it means
it's fine but once we have that
hardwired thing then we want to then our
desire to believe continues and and and
social beings may be found that you know
if they imposed some meaning on the
universe on a universe which otherwise
is hostile and dangerous that maybe it
might help bind them in tribes that may
new help might make them happier about
being alive early on because they might
be so scared of a universe that wants to
kill them all the time that it would
embolden them so there's a obviously an
evolutionary purpose to - what is
religion because they're wise and
religions wouldn't be everywhere right I
mean pretty well all human cultures have
religions each one is inconsistent with
every other one right but which is the
reason we know that they're probably all
wrong but but it works
the fact that it's universal must mean
there's some evolutionary utility to the
believing but then certain things
eventually even though they worked and
we're useful early on as our human
condition changes they may not be so
useful well that seems to be the place
where we're at now yeah as a
civilization exactly I would argue that
religion is turning out to be
counterproductive now it may have been
useful early on in human history but now
what it's doing is it's getting in the
way not only of progress but of human
cooperation and so evolution is now is
now counterproductive but the great
thing is we have we have a consciousness
we have an intellect so we can actually
overcome that evolutionary predilection
by realizing we have that predilection
and it's as Simon said that the easiest
person to fool is yourself so if you're
a scientist what you have to do is ask
yourself am i believing that because I
want to believe or because there's
evidence so if we constantly are
sceptical of ourselves we can know to
overcome that ingrained impulse we have
to want to believe that's one of the
utilities of science so I may listen to
you
one like you and I main listen to
another radio person and not like them
and I may be therefore naturally willing
to assume that they're wrong and you're
right
but I should also say to myself is it
really the case or is it just because I
like Joe Rogan I don't like you know
will you pick your favorite right-wing
not right and and and so we should be
asking ourselves okay maybe I should go
beyond my predilections me on my biases
to ask why I am sympathetic to what I'm
hearing and if we did that in everyday
life I think we'd cut through the crap
more carefully so science says look we
are hard-wired to want to have these
weird beliefs and it's fine maybe some
of them are right but the only way to
know is to test them if we're not
willing to test our beliefs and subject
them to that the test of nature then
then we're going to be deluded
[Applause]
[Music]